Hello, everybody. Welcome to another Zoom call.
We had a number of questions that we'll try to answer first.
And then feel free to put in any more questions in the chat.
All right, let's get started. Remember again, reminder.
Any good announcements will be in the members site homepage.
And throughout the member site is where you can ask any questions.
Okay, first question.
Typically, how long should I wait until I get another cheek swab test?
Well, it depends on if it's your so typically after your initial cheek swab test.
I typically recommend getting another 130, 60 or 90 days depending on how fast I think your protocol may change.
And depending on how ill a person is, we want to stay on top of things.
You know, more rapidly.
So, but you know, I've had people where they do the initial cheek swab test.
And literally, it's like they've gone off the face of the earth.
We haven't heard from them in two years.
So I think as much as I don't want to create a patient base that is codependent on us.
I also don't want people to think that they can't communicate with us.
So I think there's a balance between creating a codependent relationship and not utilizing the services that you paid for.
So I feel sad when I haven't heard from people for a long, long time in one sense.
Because I miss them. I hope they're doing well. I don't even know if they're doing well.
I also understand that some people are doing great.
And they don't want to do anything else. They feel great.
And they feel like they're going to handle on things.
And they got what they paid for. I get that also.
So I'm trying to understand that balance wherever a person is at and accept that.
But typically, I think you should get retested.
You know, after your initial cheek swab test within about 60 to 90 days.
And then after that, it depends on if things change.
So if your symptoms change, if your objective findings change,
meaning your tests are getting worse, you're feeling worse that you should do it again.
If things are, you're doing great and things are doing great in your objective findings.
Let's say you're still with an oncologist and your CT scan is coming back.
No evidence of disease. I mean, I guess I would just stay in the course and stay doing what you're doing.
So, you know, many times when we talked, I think I spoke to a person recently.
I haven't heard from for a couple of years and he's doing great.
And okay, well, that's fantastic.
But I also want to encourage people to stay in communication with us.
For our sake, too.
So yeah, it depends on, you know, I always said that you do it under cheek swab.
Kind of like if you'd go to the doctor because something changed, something was new.
Or you're trying to objectify what is going on and making decisions on supplements and diet to things.
So you should stay at top of it.
But I also know that the person is doing really well.
They may just state the course as long as they're doing really well.
So it's a balance thing.
I was listening to an alternative practitioner online who said she only uses adaptogens short term.
Because they work on the endocrine system and she doesn't want to create a dependency on them.
Does this mean there are some kind of negative feedback loop for adaptogens?
Do you agree they are only for short term use?
I am there is not a negative or positive feedback loop for adaptogens because unless you're giving a hormone itself.
So for instance, so if you have low thyroid and you took a thyroid hormone, which would be in the form of a drug.
So let's say you were taking, you know, synthetic T3, T4 combination.
It gave a synthetic.
So if you're taking synthetic and that's a replacement for thyroid.
So let's say you had primary hypothyroidism and you've been on synthetic.
Well, synthetic is going to create a negative feedback loop but it's going to turn off your thyroid.
And you're going to become dependent upon it.
After a period of time being on it.
So that's exactly what this person is thinking about with asking this question or that's correct thinking.
Is there a negative feedback loop for adaptogens though?
No, because it isn't the hormone.
So if you were giving a hormone, then your to a Terry and your hypothalamus would be sensing a normal level of hormone.
It would basically shut off the organ.
So if you were giving a hormone, that's the case.
So what are adaptogens?
So adaptogens are adapted as a classification of herbs that help, help balance your hormones.
If they're too high, meaning if you're in a adrenal fight or flight mode, they can bring it down.
They're too low, meaning if you're in a adrenal insufficiency mode, it can bring it up the same herb.
So they can help you adapt in difficult situations, hence the name.
However, there are some over the culture and one that I can think of off the top ahead.
That is not an adaptogen but is also many times by practitioners classified as an adaptogen and that would be DHA.
It's a DHA is you could purchase that as a supplement.
People buy it all the time and they think it's a good adaptogen for adrenal stress.
But it's not it's not an adaptogen.
It is a horrible.
So I don't ever recommend DHA unless the person.
If you do a adrenal stress test and it's they're just completely flat like me.
So if you've done an adrenal stress test, you know what it looks like?
You have to have this specific curve.
But if someone is in complete adrenal fatigue, where their adrenals are completely shut down, they'll be flatlined.
And they may have symptoms of they can't even hardly get off the couch even during the day.
Then using DHA for a very short turn is what I would do.
That's what I would use.
A bad product, a product short-term.
Because it is a hormone and it does function.
Your body will be affected through the negative feedback loop and could actually just shut down the adrenals if you.
Continue on it.
But adaptogenic herbs do not do that.
So is there a harm in taking adaptogenic herbs long term.
But they in effect shut down the organ.
No, they can't.
How about an adaptogenic also has desiccated.
Glangular is in it.
So like an adaptogenic also has desiccated adrenal.
Could that basically function as a negative feedback loop?
No, could there be four mode present in desiccated adrenal gland?
I would say no.
Could there be four mode present in desiccated thyroid?
I'd say possibly yes.
Could that then function on a negative feedback loop?
Possibly.
Except I still would if a person had low thyroid, they're trying to avoid.
You know, either taking a synthetic thyroid replacement.
Or they're trying to avoid increasing the dosage of said synthetic thyroid replacement.
I would much rather have them be an undesicated thyroid.
Are they going to be dependent upon that for the rest of their life?
Well, most likely if you have primary hypothyroidism, that isn't going to improve.
You may have to you are helping support the thyroid by giving desiccated thyroid.
Is it is it supplemented in a replacement for that thyroid?
Well, it possibly could, but you're you are that's the only way you can get that person over that home.
Are they becoming dependent upon desiccated thyroid?
Yeah, possibly not at all like you're giving a hormone itself.
So long answer to this is if it is not a hormone.
And it's in a truly an adaptogen that you're not going to have a negative feedback loop.
But there's no harm of taking it long term.
If you're giving a desiccated product.
Still, there's very little chance except maybe the thyroid desiccated thyroid.
And in that case, you still you need to do that anyhow.
So there isn't any other, you know, way to.
You're going to go on replacement, which is definitely going to shut down the thyroid.
I still don't think if you're taking a true adaptogen, you're going to have a negative feedback loop.
But there's not any harm in taking it long term.
Okay, next question.
I have a weighted blanket with EMS protection silver threaded lighting shield from to help with harmful electromagnetic fields and gemstone infusion natural gemstones release negative ions that could help balance and energize the body.
Can I use this with the right machine?
I really, I've been really achy lately.
It seems to help. Yes, absolutely.
You can use that with the right machine.
The only thing I would say is that you should keep the bulb underneath the blanket.
So I would keep the bulb under the blanket.
Because if it's going to block any frequencies, which those, I know those blankets are familiar with those things, and they do help nothing is going to block all the frequencies.
But still, you don't want to block any of the right frequencies.
So just keep the bulb under the blanket.
Those are great things to use that will actually could actually intensify the frequencies from the right.
So it's a, it's a great addition.
Next question.
How is a biofeedback protocol different or the same as a right machine?
What I've researched is this biofeedback teaches you how to regulate your own systems who are conscious awareness and practice its participatory and retrains your body of mind.
Right delivers external frequencies to shift or disrupt patterns in the body.
It's more of a treatment you received rather than a skill you learn.
So would do it both be beneficial or over the top with what I might need.
So biofeedback is kind of a mild form of neural feedback.
So neural feedback was developed decades ago.
And that involves putting actually a little electrodes on your head at different points of your skull.
And you basically retraining your brain to get to different waves.
So you have different brain waves.
Beta wave is your wave that you're, you're very intent and you're concentrating and hopefully your function that beta wave listening to me right now.
And you're in a learning mode.
And then you have alpha waves, theta waves.
And so you have these waves that you know you have to get down to I've said, I think last call you have to get down to like a theta in order to help you get to sleep.
Many times people have emotional issues partly because their brain can be stuck at a high wave or a low wave.
And you can use neurofeedback aka biofeedback to help you kind of cognitively control your thought processes and emotions.
It is very scientific.
It's been proven over and over again.
And it's a great therapy.
So is it, is it different than right.
It's 100% different than right. Right.
If you're using so, for instance, you, when you're talking about the frequencies of when we're talking about neural feedback, you're talking about frequencies from about seven to 30.
Is your high beta wave.
This is what I've said over and over again about when a person can't fall asleep.
You got to stop watching screens. You got to stop your screen time meeting stop looking at your phone stop looking at the TV stop looking at your iPad.
Like an hour before bed because the screens are vibrated at 60 hertz.
So you're basically in what's called doing brain and treatment. That's what biofeedback does. That's what neurofeedback does.
It's what's called brain and treatment.
You're trading your brain at a theta wave or an alpha wave or a beta wave.
Well, when you're when you're looking at a screen, you're basically trading your brain at 60 hertz, which is an ultra high beta wave.
That's not good.
You know, when you're looking at that screen, it's your your brain is firing at a very high waveform.
And then you have to get down to a theta wave to get to sleep.
Now, some people can drop their brain down to a theta wave and think happy thoughts and relax and fall asleep in 10 minutes after they after they pull the covers up.
Some people they lay there for an hour because their brain is still really that they're trying to get it down to 45 down to 40 down to 30 down to 25 and it takes a long time because their mind is just rolling.
Everybody's experienced that, you know, you're under a lot of stress. You're thinking about, you know, your your new office move that you got coming up and you're thinking about a million things you have to do.
You're planning your wedding, your daughter's wedding or something, you're thinking of a million things to do in order for you to think and plan.
You're at a beta state and you can't figure out why you can't go to sleep and your brain is just rolling your thinking of a zillion things to do.
Well, you can't do biofeedback or neurofeedback to call me or brain down.
A number of different devices that can be really good to help call my brain down to get to the state to help fall asleep.
So I'm using sleep as an example, but you can use neurofeedback slash biofeedback for a lot of different things.
But the number one use of it is in trying to try to calm an over active brain.
Not just for sleep, but for like OCD issues and anxiety issues and things like that, ADD, ADHD type additions.
I personally used to use I personally old neurofeedback clinic about what was it 15 years ago.
Well, that's what I had another doctor working for me that kind of headed up that clinic.
We were both certified in neurofeedback and it was wonderful.
It was just too much of a play. So I basically just.
We got out of that but it was.
It could be a wonderful tool. So log answer to yes, they're both beneficial, totally different.
But I would absolutely, if you're doing something like that, or you consider doing something like that, it could be extremely helpful.
Next question, would it be okay for me with the rebuilder?
So again, the rebuilder is a tool that is FDA approved for a peripheral neuropathy.
So this is this question is about would it be okay for me with the rebuilder to put the self adhered electrodes on part of the part of my knees that I have numbness.
How do I do that? Both electrodes on the same D or one electrode on one D and one on the other D.
So if you do the self adhered electrodes, you could do that on your D's one on one D, one on the other. There's no, there's no negative about it.
You do opposite sides of the body. So you would do one on one D, one on the other.
However, so you're always best in training neuropathy, treating the most distal point.
So let's say, let's say you didn't have any neuropathy in your feet, but you had neuropathy in your knees.
Nobody would ever have that. Well, let's pretend I had that. I mean, I guess somebody may have that.
But almost always you're going to get neuropathy in the most distal part of your body because neuropathy is either diabetes induced neuropathy.
And it's because of the excess glucose that it's damaging the nerves.
It's always going to be in the most distal part.
Or if you have chemotherapy induced neuropathy, it's always going to be in the most distal part because you have the least amount of circulation circulating.
The toxins back out of your body and detoxing that part of your body. So that's what where the peripheral nerves are most damaged.
You're always from a treatment perspective. You're always best off treating most distally reading furthest away from your body. So you're treating your feet is always still the best option.
So, well, I am my feet are much better, but it's really in my knees now. Still, you're still better off treating the feet because you're going to fire that older pathway.
So it's firing day, the eferid and a ferrid pathway. You're just better off going the more distal possible.
So we needed farthest away from the heart as possible.
So that's how I would do it. You could do it with the pads and put it on each day. I just wouldn't do that.
I purchased the socks that go with a rebuilder. Do you think they would be more effective than putting my feet in water trying to decide to keep them or return them. I'd return them.
I don't like the socks. It's just you're going to be better off putting your feet in the water and doing it. It's going to go through the water and it's going to treat every part of the foot that's in the water.
With the socks you have to wet the socks, put the socks on. I just the reason why they came up with the socks was because some people just did not like putting their feet in water for some reason.
So people that had a version of putting their feet in water could use the socks. I've never advocated to use the socks. I think it's much better just to put your feet in water. You're going to have a much more effective treatment.
Next question. There's a new neuropathy clinic that he died of in a soda called astute health. Do you know anything about them?
No, I don't, but here's the scoop about neuropathy. How do you treat neuropathy? Well, there isn't any secret way to treat neuropathy. They can't do injections in your feet to treat neuropathy that's going to make it any better. They can't, you know, the treatment for neuropathy is going to be stimulation of.
So other than doing the rebuilder, what are some other treatments of neuropathy? Well, you can do ppmf, false electromagnetic fields therapy on your feet.
If you had a ppmf machine there you that can be beneficial.
So some other things you could do, vibration, you could do vibration of your feet if you have a vibration plate.
Well, you can buy a mini vibration plate, which is like a foot, just a foot massage or a vibrator, you could probably buy that on Amazon for, you know, a couple hundred dollars.
I had, you know, where they're just kind of slammed to sit in front of your chair while you're sitting watching TV and you're put your turn it on and it has maybe three different modes to it and it's vibrating at three different, you know, levels.
And it's it's meant, it's not meant to treat neuropathy, but it's meant to make your feet feel better when you got sore feet.
But that can be very good. Remember, you're just firing those pathways. So the vibration. So anything you could do to fire those pathways is going to be good for your brain.
It's going to be good for neuropathy.
Well, it's going to be good for any neurological issues whatsoever. We treat a lot more neurology, you know, as I have tons of training and functional neurology.
And we used to treat a lot of ADD, ADHD patients and such and people with cognitive disorders. And so using the rebuild or them, even though they don't have any neuropathy, they go, okay, why are you using something for neuropathy on my feet, I don't have foot problems, I have brain problems because it's firing to the brain.
So you're getting, you're going to the most distal area and you're firing back to a fair and pathways to the brain. And it's very effective in getting the brain woke up and turned on.
So, so what are the pathways to the a fair pathways, while you have paid pathways.
And that is partially fired through the rebuild or the rebuild or a specific frequency, though, to help rebuild the nerve. So it's going to be more specific to neuropathy.
You have vibratory pathways, those are different fibers, these vibratory receptors that are picked up in the skin.
So using vibration can be extremely beneficial. So just buying off Amazon, you know, a foot vibration pad where you put your feet on can be very helpful.
You got pain pathways that can be stimulated through just walking barefoot, you know, outside, walking in the grass to start with walking on a gravel driveway can be a great brain therapy.
You know, how much that hurts so much, you got to walk really slow, but you're firing those a fair and pathways.
And then hot and cold, put in your feet and cold water, then put in your feet and hot water, you're stimulating the neurons.
So you're stimulating those receptors and firing those pathways. That's why PMF can be good because you're just firing into those pathways.
And it's just, you know, going to a neuropathy clinic, those are the kind of things that they're going to do and quite honestly you can do those things at home.
So I don't know what other benefit they would have certainly I'm not knocking them you can check into that.
You know, I don't know what else they would offer other than that, but those are the things that you want to do.
Things I mentioned are good for neuropathy, but understand what I, what I tied to there a little bit is all those things are also good for your brain.
So any cognitive disorders, early dementia, forgetfulness, just trying to keep your brain alive is any stimulation that you can fire.
Apparently back into the brain is good. So stimulation is so good.
And then obviously if you're trying to detox the area, you got to get the lymph moving. So contraction of muscles writing your, your the alphabet with your feet, if you can't walk a lot, you're moving your feet around.
Stand up, holding on to something and doing leg razors toe razors, you're contracted your, your lower leg muscles, the soleus and the gastroint muscles to push the limb out of there, you're helping your, your lower extremity detoxifying.
So exercise is so important.
And then, you know, just get it out, trying to walk, trying to move. That's going to be equally important.
Next question.
What would be your recommendation for my dad's continued nausea?
So, nausea is difficult when, you know, you're trying to get weight and trying not to lose weight when you have cancer and you got nausea, nothing sounds good nothing.
You can't keep things out of worse if you're vomiting.
There are several products that I'd recommended, you know, for years, what is an essential oil called digest that's a brand, branded by young living and it has, it has gingery and some other things that I'd like to use, just take a couple drops of my finger.
Take, digest, orally put it on my tongue, that seemed to help.
There's another product by, by herb farm, that's more of an herbal product, an herbal spray, that's called not now nausea, that's specific for nausea.
So, that can be helpful.
There's a product called Nux-Vamaka combination, which is a homeopath from professional formulas.
I like that product.
It's, that's just a straight homeopath. So, homeopath that's based, you know, that's in a water based liquid, which I like that product because it's homeopaths are so powerful.
It works so well, and that product is doesn't, and homeopaths don't make you, you know, just taking it.
So, some people will go, I can't take that herb, you know, that makes me nausea just taking that.
Or I can't even take that essential oil, it makes me nauseous just taking that.
Well, the homeopath world, so that's a good product to take for that.
So, those are the three things that I recommend.
The Digi's essential oil is one that not now nausea product by herb farm is the other and the Nux-Vamaka by professional formulas.
Next question. Does reverse osmosis water filtration remove all the minerals?
Should I use a mineral supplement, or should I purchase the remineralizer apparatus that is an option with the unit?
I think there's, so, I think there's more misinformation about minerals on the internet than probably anything.
So, reverse osmosis does that take the minerals out of the water?
Yeah, probably. Yeah, it's taking minerals out of the water.
It's taking heavy metals out of the water. It's taking chemicals out of the water that you don't want to have.
Oh no, oh no, that's a bad thing.
Says somebody on the internet who doesn't know what they're talking about.
You need to then add minerals to your diet if you're taking all the minerals out of the water.
And reverse osmosis creates, quote, unquote, dead water because it doesn't have any minerals left in it.
And you're going to die and you're going to have bone issues and your bones are going to fall apart because you don't have any minerals.
It's all misinformation.
So, number one, yes, reverse osmosis does take minerals out of the water, but that's not a bad thing.
So, well, why wouldn't it be a bad thing? Don't we need minerals? Yes.
But the minerals that you're getting in the water are earth-bound minerals.
They're not good minerals to absorb.
You don't absorb them well.
And even if the ones that you do absorb well, you don't utilize well.
They're not double bonded to it to be the acid.
They're not going to be well utilized in your body.
In fact, they could actually be problematic if you have too high mineral content in your water.
So, if you have well water with a very high mineral content, it can actually be problematic.
It can negatively affect your gut.
And if you do absorb those things, it can cause issues with your bones.
You can get up with calcification of your tendons and end up with tendonitis issues and all sorts of problems.
Why? Well, these are minerals. Don't we need them?
They're not the...
You know, we're not created to get our minerals from our water.
We're not created to get minerals by eating dirt.
We're created to get minerals from eating plants and eating animals that eat plants.
So, that's how we get our minerals.
We don't get our minerals from our water.
We don't get our minerals from eating dirt.
So, we get our minerals from eating plants that ate dirt.
We get our minerals from eating animals that ate plants that ate dirt.
So, and then the mineralizers that come along with units like this are just bogus, bogus, bogus, bogus.
Because all they are is a mineral, is a, is a earthbound mineral that is then mineralizing the water in minerals that you don't want to have in the first place.
It's like taking bad mineral supplement product.
So, a bad mineral supplement product will be a supplement, a mineral supplement product that is an earthbound mineral meaty that it's like the liquid minerals that are out there that are
that are a poor quality mineral that are not bonded with a double bond.
So, if you're taking a whole food mineral, a whole food product, let's say like a greens product, that's an organic greens product.
Let's say you're taking there's minerals in there, right?
Because they're in the plant and you're eating the plant.
If you go down to your garden and you eat your vegetables, you're getting minerals because the plant took the minerals out of this soil as a,
as a earthbound mineral and then changed it into a double bonded amino acid mineral, which we then consume and it works in our body.
We can absorb it well and it can be utilized by ourselves in all sorts of different functions in our body.
If we're just eating dirt, then we don't absorb it well and that which we do absorb can actually not function well in our body.
It can't necessarily be used by ourselves and can actually cause more problems like I stated.
So, again, there's more misinformation about minerals than then many other things on the internet and there's more miseducation about minerals.
So, does reverse osmosis remove all the minerals? Yes, but that is not a bad thing.
Should I supplement with a mineral supplement because of that? No.
Should you supplement with a mineral supplement?
Maybe because you don't eat any vegetables? Yes.
Or maybe because you need extra minerals because you're sweating a lot working outside or because you're doing the soda, sweating a lot, losing your minerals?
Well, yeah, that may be yes. Or, you know, should I supplement with extra magnesium because, you know, magnesium is the most needed mineral? Yes, that may be you should.
But it's not because you're doing reverse osmosis. So, I hope that helps answer that question.
So, a lot of people have that misunderstanding that there's a lot of companies out there that are even selling filtration systems that it's just they're just told they're just wrong.
So, sorry, but I feel strongly.
Okay, next question.
If my house tested positive for mold, should I buy an air purifier?
Somebody asked me this question a couple of weeks ago because they saw an air purifier that said it removes X percentage of biotoxins or, excuse me, micotoxins.
And, you know, micotoxins are toxins that mold produce. I just don't know how you could actually measure the percentage of micotoxins removed by an air filter.
So, again, I'm sorry, I'm Mr. skeptical, but I would throw a giant red flag of skepticism about a claim like that.
But could an air purifier actually remove micotoxins? Sure, air purifier can remove things that are in your air space. So, absolutely, they can.
Can an air purifier kill mold?
No, so can it trap mold sport? So, understand, an air purifier draws air through it and then it has some sort of filtration system many times several different types of filtration.
And then the air goes through it and goes out cleaner than from the back some.
So, that's how an air purifier works. Will that kill mold? No, could it trap mold sports? Yes, could it trap micotoxins? Yes, good.
So, would an air purifier be good if you have mold in your house? Sure, could be. Yes.
If you want to try to help kill mold, then you have to use an air ozoneator. So, an air ozoneator is created as just an ozone creator and ozone is O3, ozone is heavier than 02. Therefore, it'll drop into the air space and ozone will be quick to donate an oxygen.
Adam, to anything that it comes in contact with and if it came in contact with a growing mold on your side of your wall in your basement, well, then that extra oxygen would kill that mold. So, an ozoneator will help kill mold in a space where there's mold that's invisible.
So, that's where the difference. So, an air purifier, quote unquote, that is an ozone creator, ozone producer will help kill mold, but will that will that knock will that kill micotoxins? No, nothing will kill micotoxins. They're not living things.
So, that kill mold sports. Yes, because if it attaches to it, it will definitely kill mold sports. Will it kill mold on the wall? Yes, if it attaches to it will definitely kill mold on the wall.
Nothing is going to kill micotoxins because they're not living an air purifier filtration system may trap some micotoxins. So, just understand, you have to be buyer beware about stuff. I don't want to sound like I'm so stinking cynical, but there's just a lot of incorrect stuff told to us that to get us to buy something.
And I think we just need to be understanding before we get trapped into a sales pitch that is necessarily true.
Next question, if I retest my toxicity tests after working on detoxification for months, will they be back to normal?
Maybe, but you know, again, okay, so my level of toxicity, current level of toxic load is equal to my current level of toxicification, that's a word, my current exposure to toxins minus my ability to get rid of them.
So if I'm doing a lot more on the side of detoxing, I'm doing a lot more to support detoxification pathways, refer you back to the 7 phases of detoxification.
If I'm doing a lot of those 7 detoxification to get rid of, you know, these poisons that I showed positive on a test, shouldn't they therefore be, you know, lower after a period of time of doing that?
Well, theoretically, yes, in a perfect world, this problem is we're not living in a perfect world, we're living in a toxic sewage dump.
And it'd be that as likely as I possibly can.
So, well, if we're currently exposed to things, then you know, it's going to be very difficult to clean my body when I'm not what I, when I am a, you know, currently exposed to stop on a regular basis.
And the thing is, is like, oh, I've cut down my exposure, I know I don't, I'm not exposed to this anymore, I don't, you know, let's say it was glyphosate that was high.
And now I've switched an only eating organic and I retest my glyphosate levels after six months, and it's actually higher.
What the heck, you know, well, two things could be possible, still can be exposed to glyphosates through cross contamination.
Or I could be actually dumping a lot more glyphosate.
And it's just showing higher that you're a test because if you're a test, it's going to show what is what I'm dumping at that time.
So it could possibly be elevated because I'm actually succeeding in detoxifying, but more likely is, is, is more courage exposure.
So it depends on the toxin itself. Let's say I might go toxin came back higher than I would say almost surely yours, there's some current exposure that you haven't addressed yet.
And you have to dig deeper to figure out where you're being exposed to this stuff.
Or let's say if it's glyphosate, that's probably current exposure to.
So, you know, let's say if it's, let's say it's a heavy metal.
So let's say you were elevated in mercury, and you did, and then you had mercury fillings removed, it may take a while to get all that out of your system.
So it depends on the toxin. You kind of got to think through these things.
But if your test showed elevation after a period of time, it could be, her exposure could be your just, you know, you did something to, to remove a substance like mercury fillings.
And now you have a lot of detoxing to do in this kind of shows you your, the progress that you still need to make.
And so you got to kind of think through these things depending on what the toxin is.
Okay, question from the chat. Could you share the brand of EMF blocking weighted blanket that you think highly on.
If that question is for me, I don't have an answer. It's a question is for the person who asked that question about EMF blocking.
Like it.
Then I, I don't think they're on the call. They might be in the city to an afterward. So the, the, what they used was a, well, the, the gemstone infused blanket is the thorusage.
That's the blanket. It, the company is thorusage.
We used to sell some thorusage, stuff that up and out. I just refer people to the thorusages. So this is probably what they're referring to is the thorusage.
That's a good company when they have good stuff.
Next question from the chat.
You talk a lot about deer leaves you big with us, hypochloridria is that worth trying to determine root cause of this instead of taking HCL supplements forever.
Well, so the root cause of hypochloridria is the question, what is the root cause? Well, most assuredly, the root cause of hypochloridria is, is diet.
So, and remember, your stomach is the first thing that a toxin is going to come in exposure to.
So, let's say you're exposed, you eat foods with glyphosate. Let's just use that as your, as the probably the most common toxin that people have been exposed to over the last 50 years.
So, glyphosate can damage the stomach. So, remember, the hypochloric acid is made in the pridele cells in the stomach.
And they can be damaged. Whatever damage is damaged, it's going to affect their production of hydrochloric acid.
So, it did the extent that they're damaged and continually be damaged is going to be the extent of their inability to produce hydrochloric acid.
So, do you have to get to the root cause of that? I don't know how you would, except that you just have to just know some biological facts, anything that damages that is going to cause a decreased function.
So, I would say just toxins, which you could, we could just read off a zillion of them, dies, additives, flavorings from herbicides to pesticides to keep talking just chemicals that are in our food, any foods that you're eating with chemicals that you can't pronounce are, you know, all the processed foods.
And our generation, by our generation is anybody born after World War II, that's when these processed foods just started popping up.
And it's, you know, they're just full of chemicals, you know, flavorings, additives, MSG, all this, you know, stuff that they're now hidden in our food is natural flavorings.
This is the new term for, you know, MSG modified foods that damage our gut lighting.
So, I don't think we have to look very far to find out what that once is doing that.
And can your stomach heal? Can those cells heal? So, you're going to take HCl forever. I would say, yeah, for sure.
So, you stop that stuff. You'll know you can slow down with your HCl and how much HCl you need to take.
As you feel like you could digest well and you're doing well, your digestion is doing well without having to take as much HCl.
Next question from the chat, I was having a lot of pain on my left foot, so I started taking B12 and the pain is much better.
What could be the reason?
So, your B vitamins are important for your muscles, your muscle contraction, your, and also your circulation.
So, I cannot think of something I had with B12, what I have to do with pain in your soul, your foot.
But if we thought long and hard about it, it's a thought of like an acupuncture connection to what part of the soul and what of your foot there's acupressure points that relate to different organs and things.
We could get very esoteric with that and have a lot of meeting.
So, you could easily Google, like, you know, acupressure points of your foot and you could see pictures of your feet and how it relates to different organs.
And it could actually be that the B12 is helping that specific organ and that's why the pain, why you had the pain in the foot and that's why helping that out of the pain is gone.
So, those are real connections. So, they're not engaged or anything, acupuncture and acupressure is not anti-Christian in any stretch of the imagination. It's not, it is science.
So, something like that, I will take, could be related for sure.
Okay, with that, we will say goodbye. Thanks everybody for being out here.
I said everybody be prayed for everybody and we will be prayed for you.
And don't have a great week and we'll see you next week.
Bye-bye.